when i'm not out teaching my daughter
how to siphon gas i'm at home watching
yet another netflix post-apocalyptic
original trying to imitate the success
of bird box
remember the cloverfield paradox io
cadaver
i am mother arc black summer tribes of
europa
the silence well you get what i mean
awake is netflix's latest horror
thriller which asks the question can i
stay awake watching this movie
luckily i did and i got you covered with
a full ending explain some cool details
you missed along the way and will even
poke a little fun because there are some
ridiculous parts in this movie now come
along and sleep with me platonically of
course and make sure to like and
subscribe i'm so close to that 400k goal
and every bit helps
now this video will be a bit different
than my usual ones i began
it as an ending explain but then it got
so absurd i just had to dunk on it so
i'm gonna attempt to do
both awake starts just like it ends with
an image of space and that's because
this whole sleep event or should i say
non-sleep event is the cause of a solar
flare messing with our internal clocks
making humanity unable to sleep
and it makes sense this has something to
do with electromagnetism seeing as
all electronics have fried including
vehicles it's only when these vehicles
are jump-started that they can
work again at detail these super crazy
smart scientists have seemingly
overlooked in their journey to find a
cure
in our first shot of the film what
appears to be a star gets closer and
closer to the camera but it's actually a
satellite crashing to earth a result of
this solar flare
all the shooting stars those are
satellites noah
it's here we meet jill our story's
protagonist she got a job as a campus
security guard through her old friend dr
murphy played by jennifer jason lee
coincidentally jennifer and gina
rodriguez also starred in 2018's
annihilation the two characters know
each other from their time working in
the u.s military where jill aided dr
murphy in conducting sleep deprivation
torture on u.s
enemies although never explained in the
film this may have been what caused
jill's addiction to drugs that combined
with the death of her husband
only briefly mentioned in one line in
the entire film
jill was court-ordered to give up
custody of her children to her
mother-in-law
doris who is the evil mom from titanic
will the lifeboats be seated according
to class
she secretly steals expired drugs from
the campus science lab and gives them to
a drug dealer named greg
jill picks up her kids from grandma's
and gives her daughter a book about
dinosaurs we briefly see a page
depicting how birds evolved from
velociraptors in fact matilda jill's
daughter is seen carrying books about
birds throughout the film and birdie
is even her nickname not sleeping birdie
only my dad called me that matilda like
the dinosaurs will have to find a way to
survive in order to evolve in this way
matilda is like the bird in this analogy
having found a way to carry on in a
world that's going extinct
things really start to kick off when
jill's car malfunctions and crashes into
a nearby lake a result of this solar
flare wreaking havoc
jill and her son noah ironically named
after the biblical character who saves
the last of humanity in a giant arc
emerged from the water to find matilda
being resuscitated by a local sheriff
because matilda was dead and brought
back to life it essentially
reset her allowing her to sleep while
others cannot in order to get stitched
up they traveled to the va hospital
where even the coma patients have
awakened although with the inability to
function as normal with everyone
partying in the streets since the
power's out greg asks jill for more
pills he'll even double the price
so she does what any mom would do and
ventures out in the middle of the night
for some sweet sweet drugs
her mission is cut short however when dr
murphy barges in with the military on
their way to a place called the hub
a science lab where the world's only
sleeper is being held
one of the things i didn't really like
about this section of the movie was how
fast everything went it's only been
about 12 hours since the event yet the
military has already started making this
hub
learned about the sleeper brought her
there and know that everyone will die
due to a lack of sleep it felt way too
much like an exposition dump that they
tried to mask by saying
everything is accelerated symptoms are
appearing two to three times quicker
so jill fearing that the world is slowly
going to hell decides to pick up her
kids and head to the hub
only thing is her daughter is with doris
at a church where its members are going
completely insane
we should sacrifice her no yeah it's
been one day without sleep at this point
and they're already talking about
killing a young girl what church are
these guys going to
in storms brian who's related to dr
murphy telling them that matilda has to
be taken to the hub and they're like
we should sacrifice her no no he's
actually shot by one of the cops
in the commotion jill is able to rescue
her children and they take off leaving
grandma
yes sorry grandma you're getting the
boot your grandmother can run in okay
she has a condition
yet the majority of the film takes place
in a car it's pretty weird that kids
never mention grandma after this or
mourn her which is strange considering
she was
a big part of their lives but this is
the kind of thing that happens when you
put plot over character so where do you
go when you need a ride the drug dealer
of course
and he's dead these two other dealers
have killed him although they've been
able to get a couple cars working one
which jill is able to steal and while
matilda and noah are waiting for the
ride
matilda out of the blue asks noah if
he's had sex with his girlfriend
do you guys ever do it i found this
conversation
so strange since it doesn't have
anything to do with the plot and
especially considering an hour ago she
was almost killed by a group of insane
church people this would not be on the
top of my things to discuss
so our fam heads off and of course
decides to stop by a vicious accident
where jill finds the victims to be those
drug dealers from the auto shop but
what's really important here is this
badge in fact this badge will be the
item that allows matilda to link her
death and resurrection
with the ability to sleep matilda first
sees it on the sheriff the sheriff is
killed by the drug dealer who takes it
the drug dealer is kid and then jill
takes it
it's never explained why she takes it it
serves no purpose to her
but i guess the writers needed some way
to eventually get that badge to the hub
while searching for a map to take them
to the hub their car is stolen as a
group of scary-ass inmates descend upon
the town
but their carjacker has a change of
heart and ends up coming back to save
them and jill shows her appreciation for
being saved by immediately holding him
at gunpoint this is dodge and we don't
get much of a backstory on him why he
was in jail or why he decided to come
back
jill doesn't like it when he swears
around matilda because she's just a kid
she's a kid and they do all sorts of kid
things together like siphon gas
shoot books teach a 10 year old how to
drive and telling her she has to grow up
quick because everyone except her will
be dead in a few days
they eventually do make it to the hub
where jill decides to go in alone and
check things out and thank goodness the
guards are saying the code out loud so
jill can sneak her way inside and no one
seems to notice she's not supposed to be
there when she puts on a white lab coat
but hey they might be so out of it from
the lack of sleep they're just not with
it jill finds out that the sleeper this
old woman here has been held against her
will and has been treated like a science
experiment a fate that matilda would
likely experience
should she be found dr katz here even
experiments on chimpanzees apparently
the only other animal to have this
sleeping problem meanwhile dodge is
captured alongside matilda and noah it's
never explained
how they reunited he just kind of shows
up with a kid somehow
it's here when everything essentially
breaks down the entire military crew has
run off six to seven days of no sleep
kept going by a cocktail of drugs they
start to see hallucinations like kicking
pine cones thinking their grenades or
this gems
yes yes yes it's me
jill ends up making it to her daughter
who for some reason is about to be
killed by dr murphy and there's no
explanation for this but dr katz ends up
giving dr murphy one of those adrenaline
cocktails but
doesn't take out the air in the needle
apparently you can die if enough air is
left in the syringe
and this is a callback to a brief but
weird scene where grandma doris teaches
matilda how to use a syringe probably
not the best thing to teach your
granddaughter knowing her mother's past
with substance abuse
jill grabs her daughter to find noah
stabbing an electrical wire
hallucinating that he's helping his dad
gutta fish
they use the defibrillator to bring him
back before jumping to the morning after
where everyone
seems to be dead even dodge who we never
see gets shot now we do see his head
kind of move a little here which may
indicate he's still alive
jill and matilda wake up and so too does
noah who says he was dreaming the
defibrillator
worked on him and when matilda sees the
badge reminding her of the day she died
and was brought back
alongside the defibrillator she puts two
and two together that
bringing back someone from the dead
resets their internal clock
allowing them to sleep so they do the
only rational thing and drown their mom
in the water in order to resuscitate her
noah performs cpr and as the camera
zooms in on her eye we fade to black and
hear the sound of jill gasping for air
now on to save humanity by killing
everyone one at a time
i thought this movie had a really
awesome premise but all these logical
inconsistencies and things that just
plain didn't make sense really made it
hard for me to stay awake that one's for
heavy spoilers he told me to say it
thanks for watching everyone remember to
click that like and subscribe button and
for more bad takes you can always follow
me on twitter and instagram
at thinkstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you